PENG YING: Hi, my
name is Peng Ying.
And I work on the
Google Wallet team.
I'm here to talk about
the Wallet Objects
API for native Android.
I used to have a keychain full
of these-- different loyalty
cards to take advantage
of discounts and rewards.
And these I usually just end up
leaving at home unfortunately.
I could've saved so much money!
I don't think anyone but
the most dedicated savers
carry around all their loyalty
cards and offers all the time.
To make it easier for everyone
to carry around everything,
Google provides the
Wallet Objects platform.
Wallet Objects is a concept
of digitizing and storing
all of your items in
your wallet in the Cloud
and making them
accessible from anywhere.
And combined with
the mobile app that
has contextual information,
we can make these items smart
so they appear
when you need them.
For example, I
have a test object
with the geofence
of this building.
Whenever I enter the geofence,
my Wallet Object appears now.
And it can notify me that
it's available to use
through an Android system
level notification.
And we fine-tune the
contextual triggers
so that these notifications
won't trigger when say, I'm
just driving by the office.
This functionality
allows developers
to do interesting things.
Let's say you have an
existing mobile user base,
and you want to convert
users from mobile
to another physical medium.
One example, it's a
mobile game and you
want to convert the
user to a console.
In the game you can add a
geolocated Wallet Objects
offer for a console title
to incentivize user action.
With the offers
saved, the next time
the user goes to a geolocation
you specified-- whether it's
Fry's, GameStop, or Best Buy,
or some other retailer-- Wallet
will notify the user that the
offer is available to use.
They buy the title and boom!
Now they're playing your
game in the living room
in addition to on mobile.
Wallet Objects can help
with retail as well.
Instead of all the
coupons and offers
that you need to remember to
bring when you go shopping,
you should just be able to
save those offers from an app
or from the web, and
have them notify you
when they're relevant.
Let's say I walked past
a store in the mall,
and my phone notifies
me I have a coupon
to save $20 off of purchase.
I'm going to try to take
advantage of that savings,
and check out if
there's anything
in the store that interests me.
Cool.
So you want to
integrate it, right?
Let's go over how to
create and save an object.
The Wallet Objects
flow is simple.
You need to find the data
representing the object
and add a Save to Google button
that calls our function create
Wallet Object with
the object to save.
The rendering is based
on a template that
gets populated by the
information you define.
To reduce redundancy,
Wallet Objects
stores data in two forms.
It's somewhat analogous
to programming.
The class data
represents information
that's common to all users,
like merchant details.
The object data
represents information
that's specific
to a single user,
like a specific
discount or a bar code.
All this information is merged
then fills into the template.
We have a number of fields
here in this template,
and any section without
data is going to be hidden.
Let's check out the code.
First, we need to
create the class.
This code defines
an offer class.
We set the merchant and some
offer details, some images,
some subsections, and
lat long geolocations.
Finally, we insert the class.
Inserting the class needs to
use a server-side REST API.
Once you've created
and inserted the class,
you can create the object
data in your Android app.
This may look like
a big wall of code,
but it's your standard builder
pattern defining an object.
Here I'm referencing a
class I just created.
I'm overriding
some class fields,
and defining information
that's specific to a user,
such as barcode and messages.
Once I have that, we can tie
the object to a create Wallet
Objects call, and tie that
to an image button click.
And we're done.
So if you want to
remind and incentivize
actions for your users,
integrate the Wallet Objects
API into your app today.
For more information
on integration
and a step-by-step
tutorial, check out
our developer documentation.
I can't wait to
see what you build.
I'm Peng Ying.
And thanks for watching.